I have another big story for you guys
that happened over the weekend from the
post millennial suspected Trump won flag
arsonist identified using Strava after
reward offered by Tim Poole Benny
Johnson as well as John Kane the man who
uh posted the video in the first place
now I don't want to identify the
individual just yet the individual who's
been named but uh so I'm gonna I'm gonna
not post anything from this just yet but
I will just say there is a viral video
going around where a bicyclist
rides up to a TR a sign someone's As
Trump won starts kicking it comes back
later and sets it on fire comes back for
a second time after it was rebuilt sets
it on fire again in one of the videos
there's an American flag hanging above
it he tries pushing it out of the way
clearly expressing knowledge that he
could be starting a major fire and he
didn't want to he wanted to move the
flag out of the way but then it just
Falls right back and it shuts the fire
anyway he knew that this fire could have
spread to the trees burned down homes
potentially cause another major Wildfire
but the good news is he's been
identified
and uh we uh so I I had seen the video
that's at a thousand dollar reward for
this I offered five thousand dollars
Benny Johnson quickly came out offered
another five thousand and then a man in
California identified the guy here's the
crazy part he was identified using his
Strava bicycle like GPS tracker
so basically these like people who go
for jogs and bike will get this app I
guess and it will show publicly the
route you take somebody found the guys
that tattoo on his arm with like a teddy
bear or something and then they saw him
in a new story got his name and then
they looked up his Strava account
because he's a bicyclist and they found
that he rode his bike in that area at
the time of the arson ladies and
gentlemen we got him dude it's amazing
you had your Strava active while you're
gonna go commit a crime because I used
trouble years ago like probably 10 years
ago even less than that and to have it's
very accurate as to where you were to
have that on just to get the claim for
how many miles you did and while you're
committing a crime in the middle of
nowhere I need my miles though now now
this one got some lefties really really
mad at me and they were I got some
messages where they're like why are you
offering a reward for this and I was
like the dude committed arson twice man
the only way we de-escalate what's going
on with all the extremas in the violence
is if there is a neutral Arbiter of the
law that just says you can not commit
arson the idea that there are lefties
being like this man should should not be
criminally charged for this just shows
kind of how far gone we are right now in
our cultural divide yeah that the guy
didn't turn his Strava off it indicates
like what did he like where's the brain
power right now about zero people just
committing crimes and thinking they're
not going to get caught or get in
trouble Justified like maybe he was like
this sign is ruining the neighborhood
it's very long they're insane it doesn't
make me sense it's like a kid that has
anger issues and gets thrown in juvy
like sometimes you just gotta face the
music once to know what you're up
against because the legal system does
not give a and I think we should
all be against arsonists I know that's a
strong stance to take but I'm willing to
say like if you're gonna burn someone's
private property down I think that's bad
we should collectively agree if you went
back twice and you still had it going
just to record the extra mile to get the
extra miles in this accounting that's
amazing I hope they did the threat of
potentially Burning Down the House and
the area around the fire uh adds extra
charges to this guy all right he's got
to get like attempted murder I mean I
don't see him doing it but there's got
to be some charges so Benny Johnson
tweeted that apparently this guy has
already confessed to the police they
came by and said did you do this he said
yes and you know to varying degrees he
may or may not have been crying when he
confessed to having done it I think this
guy is so riddled with Trump derangement
syndrome that his brain is just doesn't
it doesn't work so when he rides his
bike normal guys rides the bike you see
a sign you don't like you go you roll
your eyes right he loses it
completely loses it and then commits
arson on two different occasions did he
know the guy whose house it was no
because that would make it premeditated
nope I can't imagine getting that mad
over anything you're quite honestly
maybe he like I don't rode past it every
day for months
actually is premeditated arson more of a
crime than just on a whim I mean he went
back the second time we must ask a
lawyer but you're right going back the
second time shows that he had
a couple days later too it's like he
must have wasn't isn't that correct like
he must have really went home and stood
on it so much he's like I gotta go burn
that thing down wait let me let me play
a video for everybody okay I just I just
wanna I don't look here's the thing
innocent until proven guilty so people
are putting out his name and everything
right now which was the intention my
intention with the reward is what I said
was information that reads the leads to
the arrest and conviction of this
individual I'm not gonna be posting his
name or anything like that his name is
on all the news articles so you can be
easily looked up but
I think the evidence is pretty damning
that identification that they have for
him but uh innocent until proven guilty
so here's the video
here here here you can see on August
12th he rides up
just starts kicking it for being a bison
no but here's the crazy thing
no but why is he kicking it he's also
trespassing what yeah absolutely what is
kicking the sign do other than he's just
very very angry wants to break it right
he wants it to be ripped that way people
can't read it as easily but he didn't
even get off his bike he's thinking
about lighting on a fire right now
he's like it's made of wood it's August
12th
he comes back I think that night
oh no a day later look at this look at
this 4 20 in the morning so see how he
tries to move the flag out of the way he
knows he could start a major fire and
then it just Falls right back it didn't
do anything and he came prepared with a
lighter like oh that's premeditated it's
like a big lighter yeah it's not like a
lighter that you use to like I don't
know smoke or whatever you use it to
start like your campfire Grill yeah your
candles this guy belongs in prison I
love how he runs away
he doesn't want to get burned surge of
course right yeah it's such a huge fire
it really could so he destroys it but
here's the thing he comes back several
days later to the Sea of the crime so
John John Kane who owns it
fixes the sign and you can see it says
February 18th John Kane issued a
correction saying it's August 18th here
he comes once again 4 20 in the morning
yep same time what the heck he's out
there with the lighter that's
pathological suspicious suspicious he
just blazed it's like a kitchen lighter
so I don't know
this guy's nuts I have 420. and they
offered a 1 000 reward you can see he
had a tattoo of like I think it's a pig
maybe on his arm but uh people in the
shower saying the Pedo Bear from 4chan
better no it's not accurate it's
probably something to do with pigs that
would make yeah there's like a pig on it
or something but they found him they
found him because uh what's he doing
he's like riding his bike at four in the
morning
that's a hiker thing though no no that's
normal that's fine I'm saying but like
then he stops to commit arson on two
occasions this guy you know he's not
gonna go to prison what's gonna happen
is they're gonna offer him some kind of
plea deal it's a first offense they're
gonna say you know you'd never do this
again he'll have to pay a fine he I
don't know though arson's pretty serious
but he did it twice and the fact that he
moved the flag means that instantly he
knew if this fire spread and it took
this flag the trees around it everything
could go up so John Kane the guy who uh
uh let me actually I'll pull up his
Twitter
I don't wanna uh
let's see here so here's John Kane and
uh here's a video he posted uh I'm not
gonna play the full video but he points
out right here you can see that
the sign right here
let's see uh that's just a flag attached
to the trees now here's the important
thing about wildfires they travel up
trees and then across the top of them
and that's the point he's bringing up
that this sign is right next to the flag
this guy tried moving out of the way
knowing that if the fire spread up this
it could get into the trees and if it
was a dry day those trees go up it
spreads around and it how many entire
neighborhood how many houses could have
gone down because of it so uh we got
them ladies and gentlemen does Kane have
any say and if this guy gets prosecuted
or is this all federal out of his hands
at this so here's the other thing James
Lawrence uh a lawyer from uh envisage
envisage law yeah we got it right here
uh was retained to file civil suit
against this guy who committed this and
now that we know who he is and that he's
according to sources confessed to the
crime uh well I mean actually perhaps
considering that he's confessed let me
pull up Benny Johnson's tweet and see
what Benny said about this because uh
then I'll we'll just show we'll just
we'll show his name if he's confessed to
it
I'm trying to be careful here you know
trying to be careful because you don't
want to jump the gun and stick the
internet on him on the other hand right
just because he's bad just because
someone posted a photo of a guy doesn't
mean that is him from a different area
doesn't mean it's the right name that's
what I'm concerned about that's why I
want the police to be involved first
this is where they reduce harm is that
one of journalistic tenants minimize
harm man that's something that needs to
be taken seriously today with all these
docs and crap people saying each other's
names reposting videos of this and that
like minimize harm but uh Benny is very
confident outright saying it is this guy
who did this thing I mean Ah that's bold
uh as we have already shown with like
the post-millennial typically in this
space people are very careful with with
direct statements of fact especially on
criminal activities but for Benny
Johnson to outright say this is it
according to my sources uh the man has
admitted to the crime and we are waiting
to see if the D.A will charge him I'm
gonna hold off on saying his name you
can easily find it Benny Johnson's
reporter the post Millennials reported
it John Keynes tweeted out but I'm gonna
hold back because uh if the D.A brings
charges then we absolutely can say the
guy's name for the time being I think
the important factor here is we're not
backing down
this is the legal way to take care of
things it is the peaceful way to take
care of things and you must understand
the the the the uh Democrat machine
going against Trump guys like this they
desperately want a violent reaction and
so when I see these people on on acts
AKA Twitter uh that are either
anti-trump or just like super pro Trump
a black belt saying there's no way to
win the Deep State the Deep state I'm
just like stop listening to those people
the only look this guy
has been found out he's gonna get sued
we'll see if he gets charged Andino just
wins one three hundred thousand dollars
against people who attacked him these
are victories you've got Bud Lights
collapse you've got targets collapse
you've got sound of Freedom we got other
new other news we didn't even mention
Richmond north of Richmond debuts
Billboard Hot 100 number one
the highest chart in the world for music
rich men north of Richmond number one yo
we are winning all across the board the
things they are doing are acts of
psychotic desperation we need to stick
to the legal path we need to make sure
we are handling everything procedurally
and we're gonna win this I also think
that people from this strata of of uh I
don't know of culture will sell each
other out so if one of them commits a
crime then the other one gets ten
thousand dollars to turn them in he'll
turn them in absolutely yeah yep what do
you think would have happened if
obviously if it hadn't turned Wi-Fi but
if the Trump sign and the flag had
burned would the charge be a hate crime
then like at what point was he trying to
avoid things being worse by avoid like
he didn't want the tree to catch fire
but also like did he want is there an
implication where he wanted to avoid
burning the American flag well I I don't
think I'm just curious running the
American flag isn't a hate crime uh even
though he's attached to a political sign
like it feels politics is not a
particular class that's true uh I don't
think this guy intentionally wanted him
to die but here's my assessment of this
man
I'm willing to bet this guy sits at home
watching the news praying for the death
of trump supporters I don't think he
intentionally
I don't think he wanted his arson to
kill anybody
however
take into consideration the hatred he
has and the willingness commit arson and
his feelings are completely irrelevant
he committed a criminal act that could
have resulted in the death of a lot of
people and that's what matters it's so
crazy how people can get so Twisted from
watching mainstream Media news from
watching like too much MSNBC too much
Rachel Maddow too much anything probably
too much Tucker Carlson maybe could
drive people insane too but like the
fear the thought that like a guy can
ruin it all like Hitler didn't do it
alone Hitler did it because he had
thousands of of people working together
I mean to be honest I can't speak for
exactly but it wasn't just like a guy
can can go ruin everything I I this
whole like fear of Donald Trump is the
most it just empowers the demon I can't
I can't say I wish that I could say this
a little more articulately but it really
really disappoints me and and makes me
nauseated to see how people become
afraid of a single man it's disgusting
and it like it and it neuters people's
ability to create and to become powerful
forces for themselves I've seen it
happen to my friends in La it's just so
depressing thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time